I'm curious before we get started who
here is excited about animation oh right
thank you thank you
you already have this now we're going
we're going to get really we're going to
narrow down this group of people how
many of you are into CSS animation
JavaScript animation guy any gee SAP
addicts in the house oh well hello
thanks for coming I'm actually I'm
disappointed she set this like the thing
anybody personally identify as a motion
designer in the audience okay
the motion designers did not get the
memo about tonight I'm so sad but good
to know good to know sweetness moving
along you may know me from awesome
projects like dev tools challenger comm
which shows off Firefox is really cool
animation tools I have helped clients
build motion design into their user
interfaces and their design systems at
scale kind of an animation walk if you
haven't noticed the themes so much so
that I even wrote a book with a book
apart I do have copies for sale with me
tonight if you buy any beers and I've
worked for Microsoft edge I've worked
with Firefox I've worked with the w3c
for a long time I'm a Google developer
expert and I just moved to Amsterdam to
work for these people because you know
only big companies need animation
experts so you're stuck with me
congratulations but before all this I
used to be a professional cartoonist and
I made web comics for teen girls for a
living around the world from the middle
of nowhere
in Virginia in the United States small
town you probably never heard of it and
eventually I had to be an adult and get
a real job making websites of course I
thought I turned my back on art and
creativity and storytelling and I would
never tell stories again in the meantime
I was learning a lot about all these
cool new api's that were coming out and
I remembered this guy here Scott McCloud
he's my favorite author he wrote a great
book called understanding comics and
another one called reinventing comics
which is even better than understanding
comics okay once again have you read
understanding comics anybody
anybody that's your homework go home and
read understanding comics it's like the
book that you should read if you're
designing anything for anyone but he
also wrote another book called
reinventing comics which was all about
how to use what the visions of the
future where people would be able to
draw comics on tablets in their hands
and there'd be this thing called
micropayments
and well his his things keep coming true
a little by little in weird ways so it's
great set of books to read so I saw
these api's coming out you know like web
audio and speech recognition and CSS
animations I was like my god he was
right the Internet is an infinite canvas
so I did this project with Adobe inspire
called allicin Videoland and I don't
mean the Swedish electroclash band
although I totally love them this is the
Allison video and I'm talking about and
it introduced a lot of designers to the
idea that they could code to create
interactive stories at a time when
Flash's decidedly uncouth
so that was just a video you could have
used After Effects to make that just
recorded it and posted it somewhere CSS
animations are very declarative they're
not very interactive interactive
animation tends to need libraries like
green sock or snap SVG or Moe j/s or
other libraries that don't provide logos
on their github pages that's why you're
not listed here still it's very tough
because browsers weren't designed for
animations others and scrolling their
rendering engines are not the same
rendering engines you'd get with like
say a game we've been missing out since
the death of flash but all that has been
changing as browsers have been upping
the rendering engine game all right so
let's do a little history lesson here
before CSS animations or transitions
over a decade ago there's something
called synchronized multimedia
integration language or we know it as
smile you can remember it's pronounced
smile like the face will smile it's used
as animate SVG's and it was created by
that slow process known as standards can
so it was born in 1999 the good old days
so 10 years later 2009 nothing much has
happened with standardized animations on
the web right in the mean time this
thing called the iPhone is on the on the
docket over at Apple and it has a
browser and its developers the Safari
developers they're thinking how can we
make the Apple website look is awesome
in our browser even though it doesn't
support flash as it does on desktop what
can we do and they introduced the CSS
animations and transitions standards
they didn't run them past anybody they
just kind of like swooped into the w3c
was like I've got some stairs for you
boy and they ran away and of course you
can imagine that all the other browsers
were very happy that now they didn't
just have one animation engine to
contend with they had three that they
had to support so Internet Explorer at
that time still still something of an
impactful browser in the world was like
oh hold on hold on
stewey animation engines you're kidding
me I can't possibly do that no no no
give me an API that I can use to
describe the animations of all of these
one API to rule them all an API that
could underlie all the browsers
animations while letting JavaScript
developers access that animation engine
it was a really big API after several
years of drafting by that process known
as standards committees spec authors are
finally nailing it down it hasn't been
changing too much in previous years but
we now know it as the web animations API
unfortunately chrome opted to deprecated
smile back in 2015 so it's kind of sort
of dead not really but you know like
good effort thank you for coming along
so we still have at least two of those
engines the web animations API is still
a big deal for browsers and animation
you can already see it at work in
browsers animation development tools for
instance
awesome tools that you can see you got
timeline scrubbing just like in the old
flash days on Firefox developer tools
I'm a big fan of Mozilla and their
products which is why I teamed up with
mdn to document this API yep I love him
so much I thought who better to help me
tell this story then Alice so I brought
her back and she's going to help us
today
so here are some core concepts the web
animation API is based on two models
it's got a timing model and an animation
model or I like to think of them as the
when as in when things are happening and
to what what exactly is going down let's
take a look at the timing model so web
animation API is time-based
currently all animations have a duration
or their duration is tied to something
like a scroll input but it has to know
where it starts and where it ends and
how long in between so these durations
they create timelines let's use the
example of the Cheshire cat he
disappears in eight seconds right so
we've got this timeline we set him up
from zero seconds
to eight seconds going from there it's
not all there the computer knows what he
looks like at any given millisecond
along this timeline right so you could
be anywhere in there and the computer
would immediately know exactly how much
of the Cheshire Cat to show this is a
very efficient kind of animation so fun
thing about this because we've got these
timelines time may be shifted backwards
forwards scaled reversed pause repeated
lets us do all these kinds of things
we call this stateless animation and
it's pretty cool you may be familiar
with request animation frame based
animations well they are a bit limited
they're limited by how often the page is
repainted basically it's if you have 60
animations and your frame rate is 30
frames per second
it's going to take two seconds to run
that animation as opposed to if it was
running at 60 frames per second but with
the web animations API if you say this
animation takes one second to run it
will take one second to run even if it's
only got 30 frames per second that's
very important if you want to make sure
that this thing is going to finish
regardless of the framerate all right
let's see what else we've got in the bag
oh it's Direction agnostic this means
it's super easy to run an animation
forwards or backwards it's a little
harder to do that when you're building
on a previous frame state and it's C
Keable you can plop down anywhere in
that timeline and be exactly where it's
a computer already knows this means
you're in sync no matter what but why am
I telling what I could be showing the
great thing about these is that
timelines have a hierarchy and they
inherit so over on the left-hand side
here I'm making a bunch of cat elements
they all have CSS animations and as you
can see those animations start at
different times on the right hand side
each one of these animations is
referencing that original cat's timeline
and adopting its current time so they're
all running in sync
this is physically impossible with CSS
animations alone all right this is very
important for level two of the web
animation API that introduces such
things as grouping but we won't get into
that tonight timelines have children
called animations animation objects line
up along a timeline like trains on a
track they do this by connecting a
single animation to a timeline then
determines what the element this cat for
instance should look like at any given
point the cat state from there - not all
there is called a keyframe effect the
term keyframe is interesting it comes
from traditional animation keys also
known as key poses or key frames worthy
like pose one pose - right those are the
key frames or key poses the keys now if
you work for Disney you want to be the
person who draws these right the keys
they got translated in interaction
development over to key frames now if
you are an intern or just a janitor or
perhaps a Korean animator who work has
been outsourced - you get to draw the
in-betweens between those key poses you
don't get interviewed about what it's
like to be an animator
this is grunt work nobody wants to do
that computers are supposed to do that
for us now
so those actually got converted over to
tweens it's interesting he got
lengthened to keyframe but in between
Scott shortened to tweens so you've got
a timeline and you know what the things
should look like it any given time but
how do you make it go well a good
metaphor for this is that the animation
object plays key frame effects sort of
along a timeline sort of the same way
DVD player plays a DVD I'm not sure that
anybody even remembers how these things
work but let's hope that we are not all
children okay with these two models
combined timing and animation we're very
fortunate because we can use the web
animation API to run every single one of
these animation engines new and dead in
the browser so here's how it's going to
do that I'm assuming everyone here has a
good grasp to CSS animations and
transitions if you if you do not you're
fortunate because I happen to have a I
happen to have a course for that and you
get 20% off with this key phrase here
but I'm going to assume you understand
your CSS animations and transitions
let's take a look at exactly how we use
the web animations API to create those
we have this because I mean in the
browser the web animation API is
responsible for them how is it doing
that well we got this animation player
and it takes a keyframe effect let's
take a closer look at that key frame
effect constructor
what is a keyframe even in the API the
keyframe effect tells the animation what
it should look like at those key points
like the beginning and the end of the
animation and the animation model
interpolates all the tweens all the
in-betweens when he's halfway
disappeared off that branch this is from
the original allison Videoland it was
done using a CSS transition you click on
the bunny and the bunny he has a
transform set on him well he has a
transition set that's watching his
transform value when transform changes
it changes to the new value in three
seconds so when you click on them you
get the class of interacted and the
transform value
translates to translate why 100% that's
what's moving him down here's that same
interaction again with the web
animations API no CSS transitions oh
it's amazing it works so science science
fantastic I love it okay let's see what
exactly is happening here we create this
new keyframe effect right we pass it the
dot the Dom element we want to be
watching and animating and this keyframe
object which is just an array of little
objects full of CSS key value pairs
right we have to give it a before and an
after at this point although we won't
always have to give it it before in
future iterations we also pass it this
little timing object which includes some
key value pairs of fur duration uses
milliseconds 3000 of them and takes
things like fill for fill mode for words
we're gonna stick it in a var and that
way we can call we can pass it to an
animation object now by the way this is
what happens if you do not set the fill
mode for words when you click on that
bunny he's just gonna pop right back to
his original position fill mode for
words basically says I want you to
maintain the last the last key pose long
after the animation has stopped playing
sort of like when you're playing a DVD
and you get to the end it just kind of
resets to the menu screen animations are
like that when they're done playing they
just kind of go what fill modes are a
nice way of saying when you get to the
end of the credits just stay there you
can also use like fill mode backwards so
that it starts at the very beginning and
just go read up on fill notes if you
don't understand there are a lot of fun
so we know a lot of these options from
their CSS counterparts let's take a look
take a look at some of our familiar
friends duration oh my gosh its
transition animation its transition
duration or animation duration delay we
know you fill it eration x' it's just a
really nice er way of saying animation -
iteration - count there so shorter more
concise I love it direction and easing
oh it's the appropriate term for that
instead of animation - timing - function
its easing and instead of defaulting to
the bizarre
and unusual ease in it defaults to
Lizzie er linear which is a constant
rate of change like same people would
write a spec so important for sequencing
here's some shiny keyframe timing
options and delay these are milliseconds
to delay after the end of an animation
really handy if you are staggering
animations or playing them one after
another iterations start when the
iteration for the animation should start
we've also got things like composite
iteration composite which are just a
little too weird to get into right now
alright so now it's time to play set
animation we're gonna do that with the
animation object we'll make some
constructors so we got our keyframe
object store does wrap it down key
frames and remember if the keyframe
effect contains all the info to execute
in animation the animation object is
what's gonna let us play it to execute
it how does that look well we're going
to take those rabbit down keyframes and
we're gonna wrap them inside a new
animation constructor and this thing
here is the documents timeline why do we
have to pass the documents timeline
because an animation constructor
requires two things keyframe object and
it require a key frame effect and a
timeline the spec has been written in a
way that allows for different kinds of
timelines in the future
for instance the scroll based timeline
or perhaps adjust your timeline but for
now it uses the documents timeline so
you pass it that in this case we're
going to store it inside a rabbit down
animation variable sweetness now
animation objects Rock because they've
got methods what kind of methods
familiar methods animation pause
animation can play animation can reverse
finish you can even cancel very
important for when you want to have a
you just want to say please no just drop
it I didn't mean that animation at all
very handy so we want to play that
animation we just do rabbit down
animation call the method of play on it
we wrapped that inside a function down
he goes which we use as a head on the
event listener for click so when people
click the white rabbit down he goes
fires and the rabbit down animation
place and after it's over we remove the
event listener just got to clean up
after ourselves so well that was pretty
amazing it's the web animation API I was
expecting applause but there's no
applause that's okay it's alright that
was a lot to go through for two lines of
CSS thank goodness we have a shortcut we
got this lovely thing called the animate
method it's great you can call it on any
Dom element it's fun fantastic right so
if your CSS animations wonk you may
notice that the web animation API it
totally handled this transition like in
animation with a big pile of keyframes
oh my gosh I have am I at 7:30 or 7:40
we can do this alright anyway all you
have to know is there that is kind of
interesting but we're going to look at
the the CSS animations and how they're
done with the web animation API right
now you can't see it quite well but
she's changing colors as she's spinning
we're gonna re we're going to reproduce
this set of CSS using the web animations
API is shortcut the animate method so
basically how it works is you get your
Dom element you call anime or not you
pass it keyframes you pass it some
timing options and boom you get an
animation here is how we converted that
CSS over into a keyframe object looks
really good I mean you can almost read
it it looks like CSS feels like CSS must
be CSS wonderful especially notice here
that we have this thing called offset
offsets important we'll get to that the
time this is the timing object once
again we've got the duration of 3,000
milliseconds iterations infinity nice
use of the capital I infinity there
we're going to put them together so
element becomes document.getelementbyid
gonna go get Alice we call animate on
her we pass the keyframes Alice tumbling
we pass the timing Alice timing and boom
so the offset is actually making up for
the color change at the 30% line offsets
are way you can tell the different
animation to only run at a certain time
otherwise that color change would have
run around fifty percent of the way
through offsets are pretty cool I'd go
into them more but I don't have the time
let's talk about what you're really here
for callbacks
okay now you're here for the promises
but I like callbacks so I didn't come
here to show you the long way to do CSS
animations let's look at the cooler
things that we can do that animation
object gives us some nice attributes it
lets us do decidedly more than CSS does
you get this on finish' promise this on
cancel promise oh my gosh
there's a readi promise so many promises
and it keeps them all pending which is
read-only it's bullying it's a it
basically informs you that the animation
is waiting to run play state which is
read-only you use methods to change it
that's a way if you can check it to tell
if it's like paused or it's running the
playback rate we'll get to you later
and effect which is kind of like the
animations version of this it points to
the keyframe effect yes
so the animations keyframe effect and
it's timing and animation props one day
we might have other kinds of effects
groups sequences more on those later for
now we just have a keyframe effect all
right more fun animation attributes
there are a couple of others we've got
current time which gives you the
location where you are on current
timeline and finished which is a
callback and I like it we're gonna play
with these two there's a famous scene
where Alice is drinking and eating and
she's growing bigger and smaller and I
thought that would make a really fun
little game it would be very hard to do
this with CSS animation alone but I
thought surely this is a job for the web
animations API and this is how I had
this is kind of what I had in mind here
you click and hold the eat me cupcake
and she gets bigger or if you go over
and click and hold drink me she gets
smaller oh it's so cute and she's such a
cute little girl I did
fun stuff with the SVG's over there we
can talk more about that in another talk
but anyway the way you think about this
is that alice is on a timeline she's
going from big to small and when the
game starts we've got a go back there
big to small and when the game starts
she's right here in the middle and we're
using the cupcake and the drink to move
her forwards and backwards we're
scrubbing forwards and backwards along
that timeline so first we use the
animate method we go out we get Alice
and we have you know the tiny part where
she's scaled down to half her size in
the big part where she's up to twice her
size
and the timing options and then we have
to hit pause fun thing about the the
animate method is that it runs it
immediately so if you want it to snot
run immediately you always end up using
pause you can see it all over in
people's animation patterns this the
organisation is considering whether or
not it should run automatically given
how often that happens all right so
let's play it through sweet that's what
happens when you don't do animation
pause so we're gonna pause her and at
Alice change pause great well now she's
little she's at her beginning state
where she's super tiny and this is what
it's like when she's at her finished
state we use a finish to set her back to
the the finish state we want her to be
halfway between those two states so
we're going to set her current time
Alice change current time is going to be
equal to oh my gosh it's a really long
way of getting this Alice change oh it's
gonna be effect
yes its effect effect timing and
duration and that sets her current time
to the end we're gonna divide it by half
and boom now we have set her current
time to be halfway of her duration and
we're referencing her duration so we
don't have to make it a variable that we
maintain so clever but so long in a
selector these slides are all available
online to don't worry I'll give them to
you afterward and then we set these
controls
so we've got the timeline we set the
playhead now we need to control the
playhead on that timeline I'm gonna use
the cake in the bottle send it forward
and backward we know forwards already so
let's go backwards how we do that we
change the playback rate to negative one
so Alice change playback rate negative
one and we hit play and we tie that to
whenever somebody goes mouse down on the
the drinking event let's take a look at
how that looks
and we go over if we hold down and all
of a sudden the animation is playing all
the way backwards there is some other
fun stuff that we do to make this fully
work to hit pause when the when the
mouse up has happened we basically make
this stop playing Alice function and we
add a listener to all kinds of things
but we're running out of time it has two
endings in the story Alice wants to get
through a tiny door so she eats the cake
but she gets huge she can reach the key
to the door but she can't get through it
she throws a tantrum she cries her eyes
out I know exactly how she feels she
when she drinks from the small bottle
she gets so tiny she ends up swimming
around in a pool of her own tears with
this mouse it makes some really racist
comments to the mouse who promptly
cold-shoulder's her and swims away to
safety while Alice continues to flounder
about that sounds like a great Saturday
night
so I made little vignettes for both of
these seeds and her being too small and
forgetting the key and her being too
large and crying herself to sleep well
good thing we have two more timelines in
both of these little anime animations
the eating and drinking animations and
what happens is that when we get to the
end of one of the animations when either
runs out what we do is we animate when
either one of these animation ends what
we do and I'm not gonna show you the
code for this is we animate where her
current time is on that plate on that on
that timeline and we find out if she is
overall at the beginning of her time
line indicating she's smaller and we
plays he's small looking up at the key
vignette or if she's toward the end
we play the one where she's too big it's
cute it's fun it's a great way you can
check out the slides and more of the
code pens on the interwebs in the
meantime I am going to skip ahead to
give you some fun information on things
other things we can do for instance
there's another demo where you can
actually change the playback rate to
make them make them go faster when you
click on them by multiplying that
playback rate by like one point one over
and over again and there's a decay on
the playback rates of the things all
around them so the more that you click
on them the faster they go and it also
changes the rate of the things around
them it's great it's from the the
through the looking-glass game I love it
you should check that one out too
way go to the code pens explore so
Rachel when can we use this API the good
news is you can start using it today
in fact I recommend that you do so it
has there's polyfill which all these
demos use I don't really recommend using
the polyfill but if you are catering to
people on Internet Explorer you might
features are rolling out in Firefox and
Chrome all the time
I believe Firefox is completely feature
complete on this edge from the people
who suggested the API in the first place
has moved into their hopper for full
support and coverage in fact I actually
recommend that you use edges API catalog
to look up the support because can I use
doesn't really get into the granularity
of which methods are supported etc so
visit status stop Microsoft edge
Microsoft edge com to see the details of
each property and its support if you
want to see it in edge go to user voice
and vote for it as for a WebKit WebKit's
actually pretty darn awesome they have
been doing some great work with this API
it has started showing up in their dev
preview on iOS and desktop so we know
that it's coming to iPhones everywhere
very soon very excited about that the
web animations API is showing up in the
wild for instance stripe is using it in
their payment processing animations
there's a really cool write up on that
on
and it's also showing up in a few
animation libraries like this one just
animate made by a great community member
of the web animation community hopefully
big animation libraries could build on
top of this API for improved performance
and accessibility and it would give
tools like Spirit J s etcetera a nice
export format for us to interface with
and of course more implementation means
we're going to have better tools across
all browsers including ones like Chrome
Canary level 2 if the spec introduces
grouping and sequencing which changes
everything gives us a very flash like
interface to work with Dan Wilson wrote
a great post about it I recommend you go
there to read more about it so all
animation is is time all the web
animations API is is time and change and
that well it changes everything it makes
way for the future animation specs we
haven't even met yet and the future of
animation online I would like to thank a
couple of great people Alex Miller for
helping me with some of my in-betweening
opalescence for doing the logos Chris
Mills at Mozilla for for helping me with
all the documentation and Brian Bertels
the author of the spec for answering all
of my questions I hope you had a good
time tonight Allison I thank you if you
want to learn more about the web
animations API visit rachel neighbors
comm /w AAPI you can sign up for web
animation weekly comm the newsletter to
get all the latest news on this API in
your inbox every week and you can join
the slack animation network community
where you can get your answer your
questions answered by the api's authors
and more thank you very much for your
time it's been a pleasure
[Applause]